hey everyone i'm hannah wallock and i'm
a partner research manager working on
fairness accountability transparency and
ethics in microsoft research's new york
city lab
i'm super excited to welcome you all to
the responsible ai track here at the
2021 microsoft research summit
this track showcases some of the work on
responsible ai taking place at microsoft
and beyond
making sure that ai systems are
developed and deployed responsibly is
one of the toughest challenges facing ai
practitioners
as we've seen in countless media
articles ai systems can behave unfairly
or unreliably
they can violate people's privacy or
pose security threats
and they can be very hard to understand
here at microsoft researchers across all
of our labs are working to advance
responsible ai processes and
technologies
often in collaboration with researchers
and practitioners around the
world microsoft's responsible ai efforts
are centered around six principles
fairness reliability and safety
privacy and security inclusiveness
transparency and accountability
we take a research-led approach to
putting these principles into practice
with many researchers contributing to
microsoft's ether initiative
in case you haven't heard of it ether
stands for ai ethics and effects in
engineering and research and it provides
subject matter expertise on microsoft's
responsible ai principles
ether lies at the center of microsoft's
responsible ai efforts along with the
policy and governance oriented office of
responsible ai and the engineering led
initiative responsible ai strategy in
engineering
in today's sessions you'll learn about a
variety of topics under the responsible
ai umbrella
including microsoft's responsible ai
toolbox
best practices for prioritizing fairness
in ai systems
content moderation
the benefits and harms of language
technologies
and human ai collaboration
you'll hear from speakers and panelists
from within and outside microsoft
spanning disciplines including ai and
machine learning
human computer interaction linguistics
law communication information science
and even social work
obviously with a three-hour session
we're only covering a small subset of
the projects and speakers that we would
have liked to showcase
but hopefully the presentations will
inspire you to dig into some of the
other work taking place at microsoft and
beyond
thank you for joining us here today
we're really excited about this session
and hope you enjoy it